face à des hôpitaux au bord de la
saturation les médecins portugais
réclame d'un nouveau confinement
les gens doivent prendre conscience
qu'ils ne peuvent pas se réunir qui ne
peuvent pas ne pas se protéger qui ne
peuvent pas être en dehors de leur foyer
familial ni en dehors du cercle de leurs
fréquentations habituelles
s'ils ne font pas cela la pandémie va
continuer à se développer et les
hôpitaux ne vont pas pouvoir faire face
et donner une réponse comme ils l'ont
fait jusqu'à présent le gouvernement qui
contrairement à ceux d'autres pays
européens n'avaient pas jugé nécessaire
en automne dernier de reconfirmer le
pays a vu hier son premier ministre
antonio costa annoncé que le portugal se
confine ray complètement pour la
deuxième fois à partir du 15 janvier
restons concentrés sur la règle est la
règle c'est que chacun doit rester chez
soi il ne faut pas se laisser distraire
par les exceptions certes elle existe on
pourra toujours aller à l'épicerie faire
les achats dont nous avons besoin nous
irons à notre travail s'il le faut mais
la règle c'est de rester à la maison
c'est ça l'essentiel
dès ce vendredi à minuit les portugais
ne pourront donc plus sortir sans
attestation
seuls certains établissements seront
autorisés à ouvrir sous certaines
conditions
les restaurateurs devront quant à eux se
contenter de la vente à emporter et des
livraisons
les établissements culturels et sportifs
devront rester fermée exceptionnellement
pour le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle le 24 janvier prochain
les bureaux de vote seront ouverts
ces mesures qui viennent ternir les
espoirs de reprise économique prenne
effet pour une période d'un mois soit
jusqu'au 15 février prochain mais elles
seront réévalués après quinze jours et
pourrait prendre fin ou s'assouplir si
la situation s'améliore d'ici là la
campagne de vaccination jugé essentiel
par le premier ministre devrait se
poursuivre à travers le pays au 8
janvier dernier
70000 portugais avait déjà été vaccinées
contre le cours aux navires us